welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is John Darnell a professor of
Egyptology at Yale University professor
Darnell's interests include Egyptian
religion cryptography the scripts and
texts of greco-roman Egypt and the
archaeological and epigraphic remains of
ancient activity in the egyptian western
desert he has considerable field
experience in Egypt and his discoveries
including the Scorpion tableau which
perhaps the earliest historical record
of ancient Egypt as well as the earliest
alphabetic inscriptions in the wadi el
hol have yielded new insight into
ancient Egyptian civilization today
we'll talk with him about his work in
Egypt
welcome professor Darnell thank you for
the invitation
you are an Egyptologist that is a term
that for me conjures up a very romantic
notion of perhaps an Indiana Jones type
character searching for treasure in the
desert
I imagine the reality of that is
somewhat different tell us what it what
it means to be an Egyptologist and what
skill set that that's important to have
well some things are similar to Indiana
Jones I guess although I have to say we
use brushes and travels more often than
we use bullwhips they're not very
helpful actually for an Egyptologist
really what we like to stress here at
Yale is the need to understand both the
written and the physical remains so the
epigraphic material all inscribed
material and archaeological remains as
well so to really to be an Egyptologist
of the sort I think that that we need to
see in the modern world would require
knowledge of the written material
ability with all the scripts including
the cursive scripts and knowledge of the
architecture the art of religion the
whole gamut of veronik civilization that
seems like quite a bit of knowledge that
you have to have particularly language
how did you come to be in egyptologist
what drew you to it to answer succinctly
it's really because of my mother she
grew up on a farm in South Alabama where
there were Mississippian native remains
mounds etc she was always interested in
archaeology so when I was very very
little she would read to me primarily
out of Egypt illogical books things that
were probably a little over my head at
the time to get me to take a nap and I
guess originally unbeknownst to her I I
wasn't sleeping I was just listening and
that's really all I ever wanted to do
there was one particular book I remember
with photograph of what I now know to
have been the letters of a farmer named
hecka nocte who wrote these to his
family around 2,000 BCE and I would
stare at that when I was very very young
and really wanted to be able to read
ancient Egyptian and it never went away
Wow
so now you can read ancient Egyptian and
and what other what other languages do
you need a lot of it is reading symbols
I would imagine right ancient Egyptian
is an interesting script the script of
ancient Egypt is interesting because
it's a combination of phonetic signs and
ideographic sign so signs that one reads
phonetically and signs that one reads as
images of the things represented so it's
it's a combination it's the oldest known
oldest surviving I guess you could say
member of the hamid o semitic super
family of of languages as far as we can
say now it is the oldest truly
phonetically written script of which we
have evidence it goes back as early as
about 3300 BCE one of the things we've
had the fortune the great good fortune
to discover are some of the harbingers
of the Egyptian script out
in the western desert in the rock art of
the fifth and the fourth millennia BCE
okay and and how long does it take one
to master I think I can safely say that
you probably die
I'm always telling students really I'm
not just saying this to make them feel
good then it just takes years and years
and years of acquaintance with it
because it's a it's a it's a dead
language and archaic offshoot of a
language family with which most Western
students are not familiar the scripts
themselves are rather difficult evolve
over time
there are a number of genres of texts
with which one must acquaint oneself so
it takes years and years of reading just
to have that sort of background and
recognition of parallels that you'll
find when looking at one text the things
that trigger the little light bulbs that
say oh I I know this this is an allusion
to this it it just it takes years and
years okay let's talk about some of your
discoveries what was your first one I
guess the first discovery we made really
was the fact that it was possible both
to date the ancient Caravan routes of
the western desert and to say something
about what the people were doing on
those tracks and how did you manage to
do that well we knew that there were
routes through the western desert there
recorded on early maps older Caravan
routes that were in use in the Middle
Ages in the early modern period we knew
that the ancient Egyptians traveled
through the western desert but in most
egyptologists a well maybe they took
this route or they took that route and
what we really wanted first to see was
you know is it possible to go on some of
these visible tracks in the desert and
say this is a veronik track this was in
use in the ancient Egyptian period
this is Roman this is Christian this is
early Islamic etc and what we found was
tremendous amounts of archaeological
remains on most of these roads broken
pottery when the caravans travel let's
say one person drops a pot every couple
of days a load falls off a donkey
the ancient Egyptians used donkeys
primarily as their beasts of burden and
the desert roads versus camels that's
what I would assume camels do not seem
to become very significant in Egypt
prior to let's say the 6th century BCE
there's some very very slim evidence
that the Egyptians may have known the
camel earlier it only becomes important
later because camels pound-for-pound a
donkey is a better beast of burden in
terms of what they can carry compared to
say their weight and what they might
consume camels don't need a lot of water
really until they say they start off
with a lot and they get a lot where
they're going but one of the things you
realize about camel trade the camel
caravan traffic is that a great many of
the animals died enroute the medieval
caravan roads I've been on some of them
in the Western Desert they're just
littered with the mummified carcasses of
dead camels
it was very wasteful in terms of the
animals and camels were used primarily
if you knew you weren't going to be able
to get provisions in any great quantity
between your starting point and your end
point so if it's a period of semi
lawlessness in an area which is the case
in southern Egypt for much of the
medieval period if you're basically an
armed trading party that's getting
through both criminal territory and
climatically bad areas if the
government's not able to maintain food
and water depots camels are why you want
the ancient Egyptians did maintain these
sorts of depots so they use primarily
donkey caravans big donkey trains okay
so we were talking about your first
discovery and
so that must have been very exciting for
you I would imagine to be able to say to
the world you know what these roots are
and with any amount of certainty it was
exciting to realize that there was all
this archaeological material and and
that we really could say something even
about the trade that we could look at
fragments of imported pottery and you
could actually say that wine from the
eastern Mediterranean coast was coming
out in some quantity out into the
Egyptian western desert around 1600 BCE
yeah that was very interesting and
important but one of the even more
surprising things I think was the fact
that we realized how many Rock
inscriptions we would find how much
written material would be at these sites
as well and since these are unusual
sites out-of-the-way places traveled
both by just common soldiers and trades
people donkey herders and by generals
and higher officials you get a wide
range of inscriptions names of people
titles sometimes to tell you where
they're going sometimes they tell you
where they ban even some semi official
inscriptions and many of these have
filled in gaps in the historical record
during periods of instability in the
Nile Valley well we don't get the
information that we might want in the
Nile Valley sites curiously the desert
sites start to fill in these gaps
because when the central authority
breaks down these hinterlands these
surrounding areas become much more
important because of trade and military
roads passing through okay and let's
talk about your favorite discovery I
don't want to insult the early
alphabetic inscriptions or the Scorpion
tableau or some of these others but I
guess I would say possibly because I'm
working on it in depth right now it
would be the the rock shrine of a priest
named PHA who who lived around
1460 BCE and he carved a series of
prayers and scenes and images in an area
of the western desert west of modern
Gomorrah it's it's very interesting
because we he left us his name in title
we know he's a priest he's not a very
high echelon priest and he carved only
what he really wanted to carve for
himself and in some of the inscriptions
he actually says made by the priests
pahu for himself which is very unusual
thing to find so we know that this was
made as his sort of private place of
worship he uses a combination of scenes
and inscriptions that you would find in
a temple and other scenes and texts that
are completely unusual it's a complete
blend I guess you would say of formal
and and informal and it has huge
implications for understanding personal
religious feeling of let's say a
middle-class Egyptian from the time of
the New Kingdom so it's really important
it's a very nice little site okay so
let's talk about what you do in it on a
day-to-day basis when you're at that
site what does your day consist of what
do you do well let's say let's say we're
camping
many of these sites require us to do
camp so we bring out three meter by
three or four meter by four meter tant's
camp and decide we have to send back for
water and food periodically with the
Rovers so basically you try to get up
about sunrise especially in the winter
it's really unpleasant to get up when
it's nice and frigid and dark and fumble
around the tent for everything but get
up and get out get going with sunrise
and in the winter try to work pretty
straight through with just a short lunch
break because it starts to get dark
pretty early and are you working with a
team of people what are you like dusting
things off digging what exactly are you
doing it varies wildly from site to site
so at pahu site primarily were doing
epigraphy recording we're copying the
rock inscriptions so begin with making
documentary photographs with scales
squared up to the rock face with the
cameras
well as you can make tracings using
plastic and sharpies etc these are
copied either back at our luxor
headquarters or back in the States
then in a subsequent season at each site
we're doing a combination of making
fresh copies and checking our initial
Incans of the earlier copies because the
real important thing is not simply make
a copy but to go back and check it at
the rock face as often as possible to
make sure that you've got every bit of
information that you can get and other
sites were clearing debris one of the
great things about desert sites is
everything that anybody ever dropped
there unless somebody else came along
and picked it up it's still there on the
surface and some of the sites show
considerable accumulation of debris
we have huge Caravan stops where we have
debris mounds that are thousands of
cubic meters of debris combinations of
broken pottery objects people dropped
animal dung that's been sort of shoveled
up into these mounds to keep it from say
blowing around where people are working
and living so clearing through that
material sifting through it wanna fuying
the material very often we have groups
of graduate students coming out at one
of the sites that do now at your site
and harga this requires sorting of
fabrics so different types of pots may
be made out of different types of clays
and if you can count them up and weigh
them you can quantify how many bowls and
what weight of bowls how many jars and
what weight of jars and what types of
fabrics and it can be very instructive
than to compare this quantified data
between the levels because you can say
sometimes by doing that Wow something
really changed at this period totally
different types of pots different ratios
and even my words your site what we
found was that it was remarkably uniform
what they were doing and how they were
doing it so the the baking process let's
say
this one site we realized was done in a
really I guess you could say almost
automated fashion like same type spots
in the same ratios same types of clays
in the same ratios doing the same thing
over about a century so some sites
they're just a couple of us working on
wrapping up copying rock inscriptions
other times we may have a dozen students
and associated people like paleobotanist
at cetera with us and we also have a
permanent staff of Egyptian workmen
who've worked with us now for years and
who really understand the excavation
techniques that you need in the desert
one of the weird things in the desert by
the way is you know if you're digging in
soil if you're in the Nile Valley you're
going through a matrix trying to find
the objects in that matrix in the desert
at these activity sites these living
sides these caravans arrives there's no
soil so the entire matrix is also
archaeological material so it's a
completely different sort of technique
that you're not looking for objects in a
matrix you're actually going through I
don't know how you'd call it like an
artifact xual matrix trying to quantify
the material trying to see how the site
form that sort of thing it must take
forever I mean is it a very lengthy
process
is it a very lengthy process I mean are
you working on a project for years and
years or I would imagine it does vary
depending on where you are but it seems
like it would take forever to like clear
the sand off of something for instance
it can it can take a tremendous amount
of time one of our interesting
discoveries at a site called tomb dhaba
between the Nile Valley and harga Oasis
was a cistern that had been dug around
in its final form around 1550 1600 BCE
it was about a hundred feet deep dug
through initially an upper level of sort
of fossil alluvial soil that had filled
eight
in remote antiquity and the high desert
plateau they dug through that a big
spiral staircase and then a shaft in two
major segments down through the
limestone to gather rainwater that would
fall in this depression it was about a
hundred feet deep and it really was very
difficult to to clear we could only stay
on site for about a month at a time
before it really became rather difficult
to keep the vehicles and repair and
because they have to keep going back and
forth to bring in supplies we would dig
it as deep clear it as deeply as we
could of sand and continuing to work on
the surrounding area come back the next
year and about three to four meters of
sand would fill in that in the
intervening time so you'd go down sand
would build up a little bit go back down
sand would build up a little bit that's
a problem at a lot of the side so what
we have to do is sort of triage clearing
of random areas in a larger site is is a
necessary initial process anyway so that
you can be absolutely certain that
you're really getting a good snapshot
that that you're not just letting your
eyes be attracted and say that's the
highest part I just I'm just going to
concentrate in the highest part you
really have to try to be a combination
of selectively going for areas that you
think probably would be important and at
the same time making sure that you're
picking randomly in your grid certain
areas to clear and usually after a few
seasons you you you get an idea as to
whether you've gotten most of the data
one of the things that I have heard
about and read is that there are thieves
and vandals have you experienced that
and since you do go back repeatedly year
after year to sites have you had any you
know heartbreak in that area for
instance we do encounter vandals we do
encounter or land reclamation even in
some of the more remote parts of the
desert it is very sad depressing thing
to have
and one of the sites of which we've
worked for a number of seasons the
waterhole was being vandalized when we
first got to the site thieves were
already attacking the site we've done
our best to try to protect the area but
as in most things it's easier to go out
and to destroy something than it is to
record it and one of the very important
inscriptions in the audio hole a letter
that was carved by a priest addressed to
another priest but carved on the rock
face so probably the only sort of
monumental lapidary spontaneous letter
like that from ancient Egypt that also
quoted from the story of sinawe this is
also one of actually I forget about this
always this is actually a rather
interesting discovery it's just a person
traveling this road he's a priest he's
writing to another priest who had left
his inscription close by so it's this
kind of joke in a way I guess he knows
this man's going to combine he'll see
his letter but in his letter he quotes
from the story of sinawe a literary text
so it shows not only that this man that
who so back had read story of sinawe so
he's the earliest person whose name we
know who read the story of sinawe he
also was able to quote from this
literary text that inscription was
destroyed shortly after we recorded it
so it's depressing on the one hand on
the other hand you realize that really
the best way to save any sight anywhere
is really to recorded properly the
archaeological and the epigraphic
material another thing I'm very
interested now is how do you determine
where to go you know how do you pick
your sites and is there competition for
some of the better sites from you know
other countries and other schools around
around the world there's competition now
and then we've had let's say people from
other marginal places try occasionally
to take over a site just pretending that
oh they
had no idea that there was something
there etc the Egyptian antiquities
organization is generally pretty good at
figuring that out so I've been contacted
several times by them sometimes they're
erring on the side of caution and I've
been able to say oh no that that's
really not a problem but but thank you
fortunately for us we're in an area
that's been rather than elected in a way
some of the more remote western desert
southwestern desert areas have been
investigated heavily now for really
prehistoric material and the now valley
of course and and I don't mean to
belittle the Nile Valley no matter how
much work you do in the Nile Valley
there's always that much more still to
be done but the area between the Nile
Valley
carga Oasis and the region of toshka in
the southern Egyptian na Valley this is
a triangle that's crisscross by by many
very important ancient Egyptian roads
that were in use in the pre-dynastic in
the historical period on which really
we're basically the only people who were
working the great thing about working on
the road system is that if you're
following these ancient tracks they
literally lead you from one site to
another site it's almost like driving
down an interstate I mean there's an
exit here there's a little stop there as
long as you keep searching the
hinterlands of the road just to make
sure that this site really is on the
road and and and you're not missing
something else about the surrounding
area it literally is like driving down
the street you just we're just led from
from site to site okay final question I
have to say I could talk to you all day
about this it's thank you really very
interesting what would be the holy grail
for you if you could make some discovery
within the realm of possibility of
course what would it be
Wow yeah difficult question to answer I
mean I guess what I would say in to
presage my answer I would say that we've
already found so many things that I
would never have guessed that we might
find like one of the inscriptions
a site between luxor and naga hamadi out
in the western desert was an inscription
by one of the local governors around
2100 BCE during a time of civil war
talking about how he made an improvement
to that desert road because his his
enemy to the south had annexed the
desert and he refers in this inscription
it's very fragmentary he refers to
warfare and it's the only surviving
inscription that really refers to this
conflict between ancient Thebes modern
Luxor and the district or known as the
Egyptians call it just to the north and
and if somebody had said you know this
is probably out there I would have
rather doubted it and it would have been
on the last thing I would have thought
let's say to find one of the things I'm
always telling students that I would
like to find is an inscription of the
second intermediate period of the 17th
dynasty of Kings second and raw who we
know fought these this coalition of
Egyptian collaborators and foreign
invaders in the north during a time of a
week central authority we know that
second and raw died in battle and we
have a great historical inscription of
his successor kumo a-- so one of the
great things to find obviously would be
the second and rosti law or an
inscription of second and raw that's one
thing that would be would be very nice
to find well this has been very
fascinating thank you so much for being
here with us today insuring some of your
work all you're welcome thank you again
for the invitation for more information
about professor Darnell and his work
please visit our website at Yale edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale